>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Wise and discerning.
>> Dignified, scholarly,
brilliant.
>> Bold, compassionate,
dedicated.
>> Rounded, open, engaged.
>> Eloquent, visionary, strong,
thoughtful and diplomatic.
>> Carla Hayden: The Kluge
Prize rewards thorough,
assessable scholarship and
strong public leadership.
And Drew Gilpin Faust embodies
all the traits we were seeking
as a prize recipient.
>> Drew Gilpin Faust:
I see myself fundamentally
as a historian.
I grew up in the Shenandoah
Valley of Virginia at a time
when much was changing but when
history also was very present.
It was in 1950's and 60's,
we lived in the midst
of Civil War battlefields.
But it was also the time of the
emerging civil rights movement.
Brown v. Board of course, the
effort to close public schools
in Virginia through
massive resistance.
All of that was very much in the
air when I was a small child.
So I think the questions of
past and present intersected
for me very vividly as
the American traditions
of governance and race and
justice and equality all played
out before my eyes
but also were part
of what I was hearing about,
the places in which I
lived and their history.
>> Michael Drake: I think
that Drew Faust was an excellent
choice for the 2018 Kluge Prize
for the Study of Humanity
because her life
has been a study.
She's a humanist
and a historian,
her life has been the
study of who we are
and how we deal with the crises.
But then her life has also
been as an exemplary leader
through the turbulent
times that we all live in.
And so she not only has
researched and studied this
as a scholar for all of us she
has also exemplified leadership
in humanity and I think it's
wonderful, a wonderful choice.
>> Edward Markey: Drew Faust is
a historian so she understands
that it's not just science
and technology as important
as they are it's the
values that are infused
into those technologies.
And that's where her
background helped to ensure
that we were constantly
lifting our gaze
to the constellation
of possibilities.
>> David Blight: She has been a
historian of the American South,
of American women, and of
the American Civil War,
and of the intellectual history
of the South in particular.
As distinguished and
as important to anyone
in the past 40 years her work
will always stand as some
of the most important
contributions
to Civil War history,
the history of the South,
and the history of
American women.
>> Susan Collins: You have made
a real difference throughout
your entire professional career.
And I know that you will
continue to do so as you put it
to help us a build a
more enlightened world.
So congratulations and best
wishes on your future endeavors.
>> Carla Hayden: Drew, I want to
congratulate you on your service
as a historian and as an
innovator in higher education.
Thanks to you both
the general public
and our leaders have a
greater understanding
of our shared history
and the experiences
that have shaped our nation.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> John Haskell: Dr.
Hayden, members of Congress,
members of the diplomatic corps,
and members of the Library's
James Madison Council.
Scholars and distinguished
guests, I'm John Haskell,
director of the Kluge Center.
On behalf of the Library of
Congress it is my pleasure
to welcome you to
the seventh conferral
of the John W. Kluge Prize
for the Study of Humanity.
Incidentally this event is
being recorded for placement
on the library's website and
it is being livestreamed,
so I also welcome our
viewers from around the world.
The John W. Kluge Prize for
Achievement in the Study
of Humanity is unique
among international awards.
The prize covers a wide range of
scholarly fields, virtually all
of the humanities and social
sciences and other areas.
It honors scholars who over a
sustained period have distilled
wisdom from the cumulative
record of human experience
and have had a major
impact on public life.
The selection process
is democratic and broad.
The Library solicits nominations
from a wide range of national
and international
individuals and institutions
and uses a rigorous selection
process involving curators,
specialists and a distinguished
panel of outside scholars,
and of course the
Librarian of Congress.
We are deeply grateful
to the late John W. Kluge
for his generosity in
creating the endowment
that funds this prize, as well
as the wide-ranging research
of the many visiting scholars
at the Kluge Center here
within the Thomas
Jefferson Building.
Now here in this institutional
symbol of the importance
of knowledge to our
democracy we especially want
to thank the Congress of the
United States for creating
and sustaining the library for
over two centuries beginning
with Thomas Jefferson's amazing
collection which has grown
to over 160 million items.
The US Congress has been
the greatest single patron
of a library in the
history of the world.
We thank the distinguished
members who are
in the audience and
with us tonight.
And now I have the
honor to introduce
to you the 14th Librarian of
Congress Dr. Carla Hayden.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden:
Thank you, John.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
I'm so honored and
pleased to welcome all
of the distinguished guests
tonight, and thank you so much
for being here with us on
this very specially evening.
John has already told you a
little bit about the history
of the Kluge Prize but
before we go any further,
I'd like to recognize one very
special person in our audience,
my predecessor, the
13th Librarian
of Congress Dr. James
Billington.
[ Applause ]
Dr. Billington had the
vision to create this prize,
as well as the Kluge Center
and he worked alongside
the late John W. Kluge
to turn this dream into reality.
So we thank you Dr.
Billington for your vision
and for your many
years of service
and leadership to our nation.
It is now my great
pleasure and privilege
to confer the seventh
Kluge Prize for Achievement
in the Study of Humanity
on our laureate.
Drew Gilpin Faust stands
among the most distinguished
historians of our generation.
Throughout her career she has
demonstrated a clear vision
and intellectual courage,
spending countless hours
in the archives and among
primary sources, some right here
at the Library of Congress
uncovering the vital research
and threads of our
country's social history.
Her work has added to our
understanding of the Civil War,
the history of the
South, and the history
of women in the United States.
By granting us a greater
understanding of our heritage
and some of the decisive ideas
and conflicts that shaped it.
Her work continues
to provide context
to the many challenges we
face in public life today.
In addition to her skilled
craft as a historian
and educator she has been a
leader in the public sphere.
In 2007 following her very
successful tenure as dean
of the Radcliffe
Institute she took office
as Harvard's 28th president.
And for over a decade
at the helm of one
of the world's most
distinguished centers
of higher research and learning
she guided the institution
through a time of
national financial crisis.
And during her leadership
she expanded financial aid
for undergraduates working
to make the Harvard community
more diverse and assessable.
And she ably promoted
the university's mission
in the arts, sciences
and humanities.
She also led in the creation
of innovative learning
and interdisciplinary programs
and strengthened
the university's
international impact.
Dr. Drew Gilpin Faust will
you please come forward
to receive the Kluge
Prize for Achievement
in the Study of Humanity.
Please join me in
welcoming Dr. Faust.
[ Applause ]
And now we will hear
from our laureate.
[ Applause ]
>> Drew Gilpin Faust: Thank you
to all of you for being here,
I know how many things
there are to do in this city
and that you would choose
to be here tonight
means the world to me.
And I wanted to especially
thank Carla Hayden
for awarding me this
prize and for taking
on the Library of Congress.
It's just about to be
her second anniversary
as librarian September 14th.
So I think we should
have a round of applause
and congratulations to her.
[ Applause ]
Dr. Billington, Secretary Chao,
so many distinguished guests
and friends in this room.
I am so grateful for this
award, it's hard for me
to find the words
to convey that.
And also to convey how
humble I feel to be
in the pantheon of
its recipients.
I'm delighted to be awarded
this recognition by the Library
of Congress, an institution
that has meant so much
to me throughout my
scholarly career.
From the papers of 19th-century
South Carolina congressman
and senator James Henry
Hammond, a key figure
in my first two books, to
the diaries and letters
of Clara Barton and the searing
Matthew Brady photographs
so central to my last.
The library's collections
have been essential
to my explorations of the
history of the American South
and the nation's
experience of Civil War.
That this award comes
from the Library
of Congress is a signal
honor that it is awarded
for achievement in the study
of humanity is a recognition I
could scarcely have dreamed of.
It affirms what I have seen
as a vocation, a calling,
a life purpose both in my
own dedication to such study
but also in my efforts on
behalf of the institutions,
especially universities
that have enabled
and encouraged this pursuit.
The path I've chosen
into the study
of humanity has been history.
From my earliest years which
I guess I discussed already a
little bit on the video, growing
up in Virginia's Shenandoah
Valley in the 1950's
and 60's I felt the presence
of the past all around me.
I lived on a farm on the Lee
Jackson Highway amidst fields
where Confederates and
Yankees had skirmished,
and I played Civil
War with my brothers
in the woods near our house.
But I also knew even
as a young child
that my own era was a
historic time in its own right,
one of controversy and challenge
to the entrenched order
of segregation that had replaced
slavery after the Civil War.
History seemed to
surround me even
as a new history was being
created before my eyes.
The past of slavery, war and
racial injustice so present
in my childhood would
later become the focus
of my scholarly work.
But the questions I would ask
of the 19th century
had implications
for my own world as well.
I sought through
research and writing
to understand how
human beings had come
to create the slave
society of the old South
and how slavery's oppressions
had become for millions
of white Southerners not
just an accepted way of life
but what they justified
as a positive good,
and what ultimately
in the hundreds
of thousands they
died to defend.
A century later I had
grown up amongst adults
who supported segregation,
a system that had seemed
to me even as a young child
at odds with the Democratic
and Christian values those same
adults taught me to espouse.
If I could understand
the southern past,
perhaps I could better
understand the southern present.
My PhD dissertation
and my first book were
about the proslavery argument.
You might say I wanted to
understand inhumanity, how men
and women throughout history
have persuaded themselves
to defend ideas, practices,
societies, governments that we
of a different era
see as indefensible.
I wanted to know how humans
can become blind to evil.
Perhaps if we could understand
their processes of denial
and rationalization,
we might gain insight
into our own failures of vision,
the shortcomings
of our own time.
History in other words,
can expand our awareness
of ourselves.
It releases us from the confines
of our own individual lives.
It offers us other
ways of seeing
that cast our assumptions
into relief.
It reminds us of choices
people have made or not made
and thus it illuminates
realms of possibility.
It shows us that things have
been otherwise and it reminds us
that things can be
different once again.
By documenting contingency
and agency history
undermines any acceptance
of crippling inevitability.
And contingency means
opportunity,
it means we can change things
and that what we do matters.
To my mind this is history's
most important lesson.
Although I had first focused
on my attention on the society
and culture of the old
South the implications
of the questions I was
exploring in my writing
and teaching led me
inexorably toward the Civil War.
It seemed I had been steeped in
that war from my earliest days.
As I began my deeper scholarly
explorations into its history,
I soon came to understand
Ernest Hemingway's observation
to F. Scott Fitzgerald.
War he said is the best subject.
For me it proved irresistible
to study humanity when it is
under maximum pressure.
When decisions and choices
are literally matters
of life and death.
When the possibility for the
best of humanity, courage,
sacrifice and the worst of
humanity cruelly, cruelty,
brutality when they collide.
And I found myself drawn to
explore with my students,
other wars as well
Vietnam, the two world wars,
what was different
and what unchanging
about the human response to
combat and conflagration.
What was the product of
time and circumstance
and what was the result of an
essential and enduring humanity?
How did the inhumanity of
war compel its participants
to reaffirm and reassert
what humanity truly meant?
And how did war extend
beyond the battlefield
to engulf the lives
of civilians,
of women and of children?
What as we might put it
was the human face of war?
It was in war's foregrounding
of death
that I encountered an
unparalleled line of sight
into the human condition and the
subject for my most recent book.
Mortality is a defining feature
of humanity and our recognition
and anticipation
of our inevitable end is a
key element differentiating us
from animals.
All of life and all
of philosophy Montaigne
once observed is
about learning to die.
Yet we do so in different ways,
in different eras,
and different places.
Facing the unprecedented
slaughter of Civil War more
than 2% of the population
died in the course of the war,
the equivalent of about
7 million people today.
Americans confronted death
in a manner both old and new.
The widely shared
Christian ideology
of the good death provided
lessons in how to die
that shaped the response
to unimaginable
and unfathomable
industrialized slaughter.
The insistence of
our forebearers
on adapting the rituals
and practices
that preserve their
humanity, even in the face
of catastrophe seem to me
an affirmation of the power
and resilience of
the human spirit.
Even in almost impossible
circumstances soldiers
and civilians alike struggled
to bury name and honor the dead
in ways that affirm the
value of each human life.
The national cemetery
system that emerged
from the war represents
the expression
of this impulse on
a national level.
For me the research and
writing for this book served
as an excursion into the
past with powerful resonance
for a future that awaits us all.
I have been deeply moved
and gratified to learn
that readers ranging from
hospice workers to clergy
to active and veteran military
have found this book has spoken
to them and to their experience.
That is just a brief glimpse
into what the study of humanity
and inhumanity has meant for
me and the kinds of questions
that collections like the
ones here at the Library
of Congress have
enabled me to ask.
Other institutions have of
course also supported this work
which would never
have been accomplished
without the rich intellectual
environment of teaching
and research nurtured by
American higher education.
Universities have served as the
locus for humanistic inquiry
from the time of their
founding in the 11th century.
Society has assigned
primary responsibility
for this stewardship to them.
It has been the unique
role of the university both
to serve the immediate
and urgent present
and at the same time
to look beyond it
to pose larger questions
of meaning.
Not just to propel
us towards our goals
but to ask what those
goals should be.
To understand who we
are, where we came from,
and where we are going and why.
Yet we find ourselves in a time
when the value and legitimacy
of these questions
and of the fields
that embody them are
being criticized,
weakened, marginalized.
Increasingly education is seen
as instrumental, we expect it
to provide a direct
path to a specific job.
We fail to ask how it will
produce a thoughtful citizen
or a person who can
imagine beyond the moment
in which we find
ourselves to see
and build the changing
world ahead.
Or how I can build a
leader who can begin
to address the profound impact
of our extraordinary
technological advances
on our culture or society
and our very understanding
of what it is to be human.
We see the results of this
neglect all around us.
We have invented the marvels
of social media but not figured
out the ethics of the
profound challenges it poses.
We have made torrents
of information available
to almost everyone but not
equipped them with the skills
of analysis and habits of
discernment to separate truth
from falsehood or perhaps
most alarmingly to believe
that this distinction matters.
We are a society enthralled
by the notion of innovation.
But how can we imagine
a new future
without grasping how
things were once different
and can be different again.
We are witnessing sharp declines
in the fields designed to ask
such questions and
nurture such skills.
I speak of course of the
humanities and what are known
as the qualitative not
mathematical social sciences,
languages, literatures,
history, philosophy, religion,
anthropology, parts
of sociology,
and political science are at
the core of this endeavor.
And their departments, majors,
jobs and enrollments
are plummeting.
At Penn State for example,
the five years from 2010
to 2015 saw a 40% decline
in humanities majors.
At the University of Illinois
at Champaign Urbana there
were 414 English majors
in 2005 and 155 in 2015.
Nationwide numbers of history
majors are down 45% since 2007.
Since the 1990's English
majors have declined by half.
The University of Wisconsin
at Stevens Point announced it
would abolish 13 departments,
including French, German,
Spanish, philosophy
and political science.
One state governor listed the
specific fields to be favored
with state support explicitly
tying educational resources
to job outcomes.
He said I want to spend our
dollars giving people sciences,
technology, engineering, math
degrees so that when they get
out of school, they
can get a job.
He observed that his
state did not need any
more anthropologists.
In fact humanists do get jobs
and over a lifetime earn only
slightly less than their peers
in the social and
natural sciences.
Jobs are of course important
but they are not enough to serve
as the exclusive purpose
of higher education.
When we define the role
of learning as solely
to drive economic development,
we risk losing sight
of the broader and deeper
questions of the kinds
of inquiry that enable
the critical insight
that built the humane
perspective,
that foster the restless
skepticism
and unbounded curiosity
from which our profoundest
understandings so often emerge.
We shouldn't forget
Einstein's words, not everything
that counts can be counted
and that not everything
that can be counted counts.
It seems to me telling
that one set
of higher education
institutions has not shared
in this recent decline in the
importance of the humanities.
These are our military
academies,
take the example of West Point.
From its origins
as an engineering school the
United States Military Academy
has evolved over two centuries
to be a very special sort
of liberal arts college, one
that recognizes that many
of the most significant
lessons it can impart
for leadership must emerge
from the study of humanity.
The Academy describes it
this way, the expansion
of a person's capacity to know
oneself and view the world
through multiple lenses.
The distinguished Academy
graduate General George Patton
whose papers are here at the
Library of Congress insisted
that a successful
soldier must know history.
To win battles he observed you
do not need weapons you beat the
soul of man.
Alexander the Great slept with
two things under his pillow,
a dagger and a copy
of Homer's Iliad.
To understand the human soul,
no small aspiration but one
that has propelled my work
for decades and the work
of the humanities for millennia.
In identifying what is
distinctively human we
necessarily commit ourselves
to its preservation
and enhancement.
To the appreciation of
what unites us rather
than the distraction
of what divides us.
To the advancement of
the humane in a world
that often seems bent
on destroying it.
We must support universities
in their dedication
to these efforts and we
must adopt a discourse
that honors rather
than disparaging these
fields of inquiry.
But to make this
possible and sustainable
within universities we must
also build broader understanding
of the importance of the study
of humanity outside
and beyond them.
And so let me return
to where I began,
to where we find
ourselves tonight.
In serving as the Library
of Congress this institution
must also serve all the people
that Congress represents.
Not just scholars but
the curious citizens
of an entire nation.
All of us are in this
room because we are
in some way connected
to that work.
Because we are somehow
invested in that endeavor.
The extraordinary advances
of science and technology
that lie before us
must be shaped by human
and humane purposes
if those values
and perhaps even humankind
are not to be destroyed.
Let me invoke the historian
sense of contingency
that I earlier described.
It is up to us to
define the nature
and quality of human
possibility.
The contents of this
library can help inspire us
to inspire others to understand
what those possibilities
might be.
Let me make this
point by closing
with a treasure from
the library.
I spoke earlier of
the face of war.
The Library of Congress
possesses a remarkable
collection of I understand now
more than 3,500 Civil War faces
that has been assembled and
donated by Tom Liljenquist
who is here in the audience
and his three young sons.
Inspired by newspaper
photographs of US servicemen
and servicewomen killed in Iraq
and Afghanistan the Liljenquists
regard their collection
of tintypes and ambrotypes
as a memorial
to the soldiers of
the Civil War.
This gives you a general
portrait but here is one
of the ambrotypes
from the collection.
It's been tentatively identified
as Sergeant Samuel Smith,
his wife Molly and
daughters Mary and Maggie.
The image was found in Cecil
County, Maryland so it's likely
that this soldier was in
one of seven regiments
of United States colored
troops raised in that state.
Like all of the portraits
in this collection it
speaks eloquently to us
across the century and a
half that separates us.
For this soldier and his family
the message is one of pride
and affirmation of the new
freedoms war had enabled him
to claim.
Slavery would have denied him
the right to legally marry
or to protect his wife
and children from sale.
This portrait is of a free
man, it proclaims a new day
for black families, a new
respectability of fine clothing,
and of daughters in
matching coats and bonnets.
And it portrays a soldier,
an African-American
who under slavery would've been
prohibited from bearing arms,
and who until 1863 could not
have enlisted in the Army.
Now he has joined what would
be nearly 200,000 other black
Americans to fight for freedom,
to risk enslavement if captured,
and to establish a claim to
full citizenship and humanity
as the republic's old defenders.
In this photograph
Sergeant Smith
or whoever this might
be makes a statement
about a new order of things.
It is his own declaration
of independence,
his personal affirmation
that all men
that he has been created
equal, that he is fighting
for a new birth of freedom.
But these 3,500 portraits
and thousands more
like them are intended to send
us another message as well,
one that speaks directly to the
meaning of the study of humanity
across time and space.
These soldiers staring into
the photographer's lens are
self-consciously
reaching through history.
They are documenting their
faces and their uniforms partly
because they know they may be
killed in the battles ahead.
But they also know they are
making history in this war
and they want to
capture that for us.
Attention must be paid they
are saying, don't forget
who we were and what we did.
Let us give you the
means to see us,
to understand us long
after we are gone.
Our present is delivered
to us at a price paid
by those who came before.
History helps us remember
our accountability to them,
as well as our obligations
to more than just ourselves
and more than just our own time.
It is a way of knowing
and valuing
that has never mattered more.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> John Haskell: Thank you for
those aspiring words Dr. Faust
and all of us at the library
look forward to working
with you in the future.
I know I can speak
for all of us on that.
And I now invite everybody
to make your way upstairs
for dinner, and thank you again.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit
us at LOC.gov.